welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
Gayle King with Anthony Mason and Tony
to copal a man long suspected of
exploiting and manipulating his
daughter's college friends is in jail
this morning
his name is Lawrence ray he's 60 years
old he was arrested yesterday by the FBI
and New York Police Department on
charges including sex trafficking money
laundering extortion and forced labor
prosecutors say the abuse started years
ago when rape moved in with his daughter
at Sarah Lawrence College in her dorm
room
Errol Barnett is at the campus that's
just north of New York City Aeros so
many apparent issues here how far back
does this go good morning well Gail
Lawrence ray moved in with his daughter
back in 2010 after a jail stick he
effectively told her and she was a
sophomore here at the time but he just
needed a place to crash for a while that
is when the alleged abuse began the
conduct alleged here is outrageous it
makes you angry if you're not angry
office'll after years of allegations
about unspeakable abuse against young
people he met as college students six
year old Lawrence ray was arrested at
this New Jersey home on Tuesday one of
his daughters roommates and one of the
female victims in the indictment were in
the residence at the time according to
the indictment ray held so-called
therapy sessions in his daughter's dorm
alienating several of the victims from
their parents after earning their trust
the document says he controlled them by
using verbal and physical abuse which
escalated after he and some of the
victims later moved to New York City the
indictment also charges ray with
depriving his victims of food and sleep
and taking explicit pictures of some of
them prosecutors say he accuse him of
lying and stealing and in response they
say he asked for money eventually
extorting nearly a million dollars ray
directed his victims to obtain money for
him by other means by draining their
parents savings and worse forced labor
and prostitution ray is also accused of
demanding taped confessions from his
victims for supposed crimes they
committed do you make this fine
freewill yes in this video uploaded in
2017 an apparently disoriented young
woman says she tried to poison ray an
unsubstantiated allegation did you in
fact poison me yes the investigation
into Ray was prompted by this New York
magazine article from April of last year
James Walsh co-wrote the piece these
students were just curious open to the
world looking for somebody interesting
to latch onto and who could share wisdom
about the world and Larry was that
person in a statement Sarah Lawrence
College said student safety is a
priority it says an internal
investigation done in 2019 about the
accusations in the article did not
substantiate those specific claims I
don't think people a lot of people we
spoke to didn't maybe understand the
extent of it or the seriousness or the
fact that it had gone on for so long but
certainly students around campus knew
about it
now Walsh also tells CBS News additional
alleged victims have come forward since
this article was published with
accusations of their own that date back
to the 1990s Ray is scheduled to be
arraigned in a New York City courtroom
this afternoon and faces a maximum
sentence of life in prison and Tony just
one other note before I throw it back to
you his court-appointed attorney has not
been identified so we do not have
comment from Ray's point of view just
yet
it's just an absolutely shocking story
Errol thank you very much